harford research stunned to discover
farts that fight fat weird but true
science now shows these fat fighting
farts can help you poop out up to one
point one three pounds of extra fat per
week asterisk earn up to four hundred
and thirty seven percent more fat in the
same time asterisk shrink existing fat
cells by 28% block new fat cells from
forming masters and much mole this may
be the strangest letter you've ever read
because in the wedding we're gonna talk
about some weird things like farts
pooping out fat mind controlling micro
bugs even the FBI but on the other hand
what I'm about to tell you is a very
serious matter for people struggling
with weight because it's finally gonna
explain why it's practically impossible
for any diet or how to finally enjoy
what being naturally lean feels like and
why your farts play a powerful role in
your ability to lose weight and don't
worry this is not some weird radical
theory cooked up by a random health
bother trying to create controversy
my name is Jeremy Reeves and I'm not
naturally lean either believe it or not
I used to turn off the light before
being intimate with my wife because I
was embarrassed of how I looked and
that's because back then I was over 200
pounds just five nine and very flabby
puffy face and confidence at an all-time
low here's what I used to look like then
I discovered the secret that I'm about
to share with you how to stay
consistently lean strong healthy and
confident here's me with my crazy kiddos
these pictures definitely do not look
absolutely identical these are not the
same person having lost no weight at all
because this one is beyond that odd and
dad bod ain't got nothing on me now now
what are we selling probiotics are we
ever gonna talk about fat fighting farts
again no way that was just a hook you in
now we're getting to the point in our
program where we're gonna talk to you
guys about our nutritional expert guys
now as you guys know it's important to
build some Authority when you're selling
a health supplement even a health
supplement as common as probiotics so
I'm gonna introduce you guys to our
physician nutritional expert and almost
FBI agent dr. Michael Feli dr. Michael
Feli is a podiatrist
what's a podiatrist well he's a foot
doctor now what does that have to do
with that with a health supplement I
have no idea but I'm thinking that
you're thinking the doctor sounds like
he's pretty smart and you're gonna
ignore that hiring a podiatrist to make
a health supplement is kind of like
hiring an electrician to fix your pipes
now we're gonna get to the sales part of
the page where you can buy one bottle of
our probiotic for 4995 and I want to
draw you away from Amazon where you can
buy basically the same kinds of products
for 1879 so I hope you're big enough
sucker to go ahead and buy this and if
you are I want you to know that your dad
bod is going to melt away just like mine
did happy farting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]